we're back at resorts world las vegas
the party is heating up but it's
definitely cold outside luckily the
drinks are flowing keeping everybody
warm but here is the big question
michael every new year's
what should you be drinking on new
year's eve well we went to a real expert
wait do you see what i did there to find
out the best cocktail for tonight she's
one of my dear friends i absolutely love
her you know from the real housewives of
oc
heather de bro
first of all happy new year happy new
year happy new year do you have a
resolution before we start for 2022 um
oh
okay we'll get to that
so what are we drinking on new year's
eve all right well it's new year's eve
and you know i know my name is a little
synonymous with jesus which is of course
what we like to drink on new year's eve
so we're going to open up this champagne
and i am going to show you something fun
that i love to do so you know i'm from
new york but i'm transplanted to
california and my family's taking a
little tropical vacation okay this year
so in honor oh
so in honor of that my reaction was the
best
we're going to make a fancy champagne
drink this tulip shape is the best for
champagne gives you the most bubbles and
aerates the wine so you get the best
taste we're going to take our pineapples
and first we are going to cut the top
clean off then we're going to take our
corer and just pull it out there
save the pineapple because it's
delicious and then there's really not a
great tool for cutting out that core i
really need to that's what i need to
invent so now i'm going to put i'm going
to use crunchy ice now if you know
anything about my house you'll know
famously we have lots of different types
of ice in the house this is the crunchy
eyes people keep asking me is it true
that there's air in there so it doesn't
hurt your teeth it's true and then wow
watch this
pour our champagne
whoa
and then we're just going to add this
and we're going to add a little umbrella
and we're going to add a straw
and voila now let me tell you what's
really amazing about this
now do you remember like in the old days
they used to have that that vodka
infused yes with the fruit same idea and
what you do is you squish it
just a little bit okay to release the
juice to release the juice and now
voila
so i wish you both an incredible 2020
filled with champs and pineapples and
love
cheers happy new year happy new year
happy 2022. cheers
and we brought the drinks to set worship
michael you gotta squeeze it to get to
juicing clink and drink
drink i don't think pineapples clank but
we can drink but i tell you what we
filled these with provocativo
yeah we're getting our drinks on right
now delicious
this is what i'm talking about this is
all this is what's happening for new
year's this is honestly i mean i love
her and i want to be her best friend
forever but she
makes the best drink i think i've ever
had it is so good because it's just got
that little bit of an infusion i thought
the pineapple was just for fun like it
would you wouldn't taste it but you
taste it right away right away so
good plus you got heather's company